all right there's plenty of different
summer programs for the kids to enjoy I
know my daughter is in one but we're
covering this morning the Royal
Treatment that's right princess
summer school your child will learn and
grow with their favorite princesses
Laura negretti has a preview oh bippity
boppity look at her
bippity boppity boo
is right you mentioned
you know you mentioned uh you know have
an A Fairy Godmother you guys I became
my fairy Godmother good morning
if you may recognize this familiar face
hello all the way from Arendale hello
hello thanks for being with us okay so
this is Princess summer school it's a
whole lot to love here it's all
happening next week 450 for the week but
there is so much going on you know
educational activities talk to me about
some things that happen out here and
then also what happens with a princess
makeover yes well one of our favorite
things that we do is our princess
makeover and the kids of course love it
every single time so first you're going
to get an amazing costume so of course
we have our Fairy Godmother here and as
you can see these are our wonderful
costumes
perfect and then we'll get without
further too whoops in there uh without
further Ado um
Glitz me up
so we have our fun glitter hairspray
after they get some glitter makeup
that's nice and cool okay is it
translating oh wow you are very glittery
very glittery I feel very glittery and
then also the Keepsake here of course
the crown all of the children get their
wonderful little Crown let me make sure
that stays in there but what's so what's
so great too is they get to keep all of
these little keepsakes you know the
makeover happens at the end of the week
thank you so so much by the way of
course yeah the makeover happens at the
end of the week but every single day new
activities and fun keepsakes and again
they get to keep the dresses and the
Tiaras afterwards so again princess
parties usa.com for now live over here
Lauren negrady for eight news now back
over to you guys
thank you